we are getting studio for turned into a
bad guy lair the great thing about
having a 3,000 square-foot warehouse is
when you need to film things and unlike
the old days we were forced to film out
projects to do we can choose inside if
we just do a little art decoration and
modification oxygen kamenets dude like
get on the train because it's the
chuggins it works every time no wait
Jake so what exactly is my role in this
for you you're bad guy
it might be that guy or just um you're
good on to the goon factory with a
triplet with a fresh tracksuit eight
balaclava in your back pocket let's say
so does that mean I'm playing more than
one person yes Drake
backs up into me sorry - I came from the
dentist this morning my num is numb and
I feel kind of high so here's what we're
going to do this morning we're going to
have a knife fight it really helps you
know get people in the mindset of going
after the weak and really attack and the
projects that they're working on so grab
your weapons
everybody hold the first thing about
legs - will you learn in the process if
you get hit in the limb you lose that
limb who's first one big one
[Music]
Wow
Garrett Burton's red hahaha
me versus Garrett this should be easy
[Music]
give me that nice big I've learned Nick
that's great that you can beat one
person with a knife but can you beat two
right let's do this yeah kind of all
this happens
I have no challenges today because we
got these awesome Sigma cinema zoom
lenses t2 we have at 18 to 35 t2 and we
have this 50 to 100 do those come on
while ago this and three in want action
he's a flying hover board man yeah he's
big huh
I don't really know what the backward I
don't a lot of back story written
there's there's some really intense
dialogue like watch out get out of here
stuff like that I'm trying to
internalize that dialogue to develop
this character that's just when you're
everything sure get out
pretty it is great I'm working on
working progress we're going to be
flipping from here to here we'll be
moving this wall out we'll still be in
the same space but then this character
enters and then there's a whole setup
and all the bad guys no sign of the
launch code looking for this you'll
never get away with it watch right let's
do this call this crap
[Music]
[Applause]
I sacrificed myself but Ren could get
the kill blocking up of the rest of it
right now GoPro on the gun while I'm
sitting here
that's it for the bikes and the fight is
over
they exploit Etonians you want to have
the Horde fly on its own accord across
there's a shot in this video that Jake
really wanted to get where he actually
propels the hoverboard into the bad
breath threat bed he specifically wants
to have the tires spinning out while
standing on it this defies the laws of
physics but it doesn't defy the laws of
visual effects first we get a clean
plate which is nothing in the frame then
we get the shot of just the hoverboard
sitting there for reference when we put
our hands on it we can actually activate
the sensors but force it not to go
anywhere at the same time so that will
get us to get that like that vibrating
effect finally with the shot of Jake's
legs sitting there clean with no
hoverboard in the frame so we also want
to get the same parallax in the frame if
he was just sitting on the ground when I
crop it out and move it up it's going to
look weird because the angle is now off
the perspective so we want to lift him
up by putting on that Apple watch or 1/2
Apple box in our case can I'm right
roughly around where his feet would be
if he was actually standing on the board
in visual effects we'll cut everything
out put it back on top of each other
render and profit is the sort of thing
that could take me half an hour or it
could take me 3 or 4 hours I don't quite
know until I see the footage to
persecute me and Ren versus Carmichael
and Jarrod don't get it guys
[Music]
oh you put my face we're gonna give him
a second chance for the final fight if
every man for himself
everyone has knives no one's on each
other
[Music]
[Applause]
ah I'm rendering a spaceship but in the
meantime the reason why I could even do
spaceships stuff is because of you guys
specifically those of you who support us
on patreon thank you and even more
specifically is thank you to these five
individuals masters of the realm
Andrew Ryan longtime fan John Welch
longtime fan so local I also known as
those heroes longtime fan I got James
Bailey a longtime fan and of course
Richard Blackford I don't know
Blackburn I like your name though like
medieval toast burning name I don't know
thank you so much for supporting us on
patreon as you can see I actually Molly
and 3d printed a plaque with your names
on it it failed because I tried
switching filament so that I can have a
blue plaque and red letters but put it
in sharpie so patreon.com slash corridor
digital if you want to support us there
and help us make even better content
thanks
[Music]
here's your backpack there's a laptop in
there Oh God
also big thanks to these patients we
couldn't do it without one more
free-for-all
[Music]
yeah I think what we learned from this
is that Jarrod secretly has a prison
life way to know that our endorphins are
up yeah it's work boom
kirpan mission accomplished